[Música]
hmm
ciência e magnésio,
como comparação também as temperaturas de visibilidade,
há mais nas minhas chaves em
torno de outras variáveis impossíveis [Mús
ca] [Mús
ca] [Riso
] [Mús
ca] [Mús
ca  ]
[Música]
estrangeira
é
[Música]
um
estrangeira
[Música]
[Música] [Música]
estrangeira
[Música]
nós
é
[Música]
estrangeira
um
[Música]
sim
estrangeira
[Música]
é
me
[Música]
estrangeira
[Música]  ]
uh
[Música]
estrangeira
que é a única pessoa que eu acho que
é sequência que você mal deve
comunicar através das histórias que foram
preservadas pelas pessoas
aqui é o nosso tempo todo
[Música]
[Música  ]
um
[Música]
estrangeira
[Aplausos]
[Música]
estrangeira
oh
[Aplicativo  ause]
[Música]
você